from Texas we move further north to the
state of North Dakota and a Democratic
incumbent on the ropes senator Heidi
Heitkamp says a staff member responsible
for an incredibly embarrassing mistake
is no longer on her campaign a newspaper
ad for Heitkamp aimed at attacking
Republican Kevin Cramer used names for
sexual assault victims without their
permission and falsely named other women
as survivors of attacks correspondent
Ellis Barbara looks at the fallout
tonight if you open a paper in North
Dakota this past Sunday you might have
seen an open letter to Republican
congressman and Senate hopeful Kevin
Cramer the letter a political ad paid
for by incumbent Democratic senator
Heidi Heitkamp told Cramer he's wrong
about the me2 movement that it is not as
he said a movement towards victimization
over 100 people signed it the letters
had all suffered from domestic violence
sexual assault or rape but at least five
women have taken to social media saying
they didn't give anyone permission to
use their names at least three are now
asking for legal help Rob port a
conservative radio host was one of the
first to notice the post a lot of them
work for most they were scared and one
of the first to speak with Heitkamp this
was a major mistake on our campaigns
part and I can't say I'm sorry enough I
am so so sorry that this happened I'm
trying to reach out and make sure that
it's right that we make it right it
appears that there was a major failing
as to a group of women who were part of
a stream on Facebook that's as much as
what we know right now senator Heidi
Heitkamp is considered one of the most
vulnerable Senate Democrats this
election cycle she voted against justice
Brett Kavanaugh when the majority of
North Dakota voters supported it the
latest Fox News poll put Kramer ahead of
Heitkamp by 12 points a month ago he was
only up by 4 Heitkamp lost support among
women and analysts say perhaps that the
open letter was aimed at senator
Heitkamp before she was a senator was
also Attorney General and sexual
violence domestic violence in general
have been a very important part of her
portfolio and it's a question of whether
this ad is going to end up
hurting her standing on that issue or if
her previous work on that will sort of
buttress her republicans are hitting
height camp over this saying that she
exploited people for political gain we
invited senator Heitkamp to speak with
us her campaign said she is in North
Dakota right now and unavailable but
they did tell Fox News the campaign
fired a staffer who worked on that
letter they did not name the staffer
right Allison thank you